[Music]
as
deadline reported a couple of days ago
there is a new cast for the upcoming
john week four
we're talking about the japanese british
singer rina savayama who released her
first music album last year
the 30 year old who has been highly
priced in the music world is now making
her acting debut in john wick 4
alongside leading actor kiana reeves
at this point it's hard to say whether
she will be friendly or hostile to a
john wick
the movie crew seems to be looking
forward to the debutant though with
director chad stehalski stating that
they are looking forward to savayama's
incredible talent
she may even establish a new character
that will return in potential for the
john wick films
we are excited to see the newest edition
and of course look forward to the us
release of john wick chapter 4
on may 27 2022
after the end of season 3 of the netflix
animated series jurassic world camp
cretaceous the way is now clear for new
adventures
appropriate to the end producer colin
trevorrow comments on the future of the
animated series
he was pleased that there was a clear
winner at the end after the series has
so far incorporated the events of
jurassic world and jurassic world the
fallen kingdom
in the latter illinois is indeed
destroyed by the eruption of mount sibo
in an epic yet heartbreaking scene which
is why fans are wondering if this moment
will
also be featured in the series
chronologically it would match since
camp cretaceous has now
arrived at about the appropriate point
in the jurassic world timeline
trevor however believes it will be left
as a one-off as many fans had been upset
with the scene in the film
instead he offers a small preview of
season 4 of the netflix series
the intention is to turn away from the
movies more in the future and explore
new areas in spite of everything of
course in the same universe
regarding the fan favorite bumpy trevor
also has reassuring news saying that
there is no reason to worry about the
safety of the baby ankylosaurus
there's a final bit of good news
regarding the upcoming jurassic world
dominion
as the producers hinting at an upcoming
trailer as part of a promo event aimed
at getting people in the theaters
this means we could see a first teaser
for the trilogies finale within the next
few weeks
we are definitely excited and look
forward to the release on june 10th 2022
the last mcu appearance of thor in
avengers nk was rather marked by a
canned peer in video games rather than a
body as hard as steel
as new pictures show a lot of time has
passed since then because chris
hemsworth is more toned than ever for
the upcoming thor
love and thunder in the image on the
occasion of the last day of shooting he
can be seen in tank top and massive arms
while taika waititi stands next to him
in typical fashion as cork
the internet is of course cracking up in
light of the new
thor and so hemsworth is already part of
many memes
we are definitely eager to see what the
37 year old looks like in the completed
film
the upcoming mcu adventure will be
released in cinemas on may 6
2022 the rumors surrounding the upcoming
spider-man no way home keep growing
the latest news should make many fans
happy because collider chef jeff snyder
announced the return of willem defoe in
his podcast
he played the character norman osborne
later also known under his villain name
green goblin in the first spider-man
with tobey maguire
allegedly he will also lead the sinister
six in the future which in addition
consists of electro
dr octopus sandman reno and lizard the
appearance of the 65 year old has not
yet been officially confirmed which is
why we should still be
somewhat careful with hasty conclusions
however
emma stone is definitely part of the
cast she actually confirmed the
persistent rumors about her character
gwen stacy
and the amazing spider-man 2. gwen stacy
is so to speak the counterpart to mary
jane but only in the amazing spider-man
movies
one last piece of news about the mcu
adventure comes from an interview with
sony pictures where it was officially
announced that spider-man no way home
will mark the superhero's arrival
and the spidey-verse the deal between
marvel and sony also calls for a total
of three standalone films three minor
roles in mcu films as well as the option
for
one more appearance the standalone
movies are covered with a homecoming
far from home and no way home as well as
appearances in civil war
infinity war and end game leaving one
more appearance which will most likely
be in the upcoming doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
thereafter tom holland will have to
leave the mcu behind so that sony
spider-verse can finally kick
into high gear spider-man no way home
will be released in theaters on december
17
2021
all the more pleasing that a few days
ago producer seth rogen posted the
release date as well as a sketch via
twitter
rogan who has already proven his skills
in series such as preacher or
the boys will now be in charge of the
completely cgi animated feature film
together with his companions
evan goldberg and james weaver the
content of the film
is still largely unclear last year at
least rogan hinted that the movie will
take a coming-of-age direction
the cgi film about leonardo donatello
raphael and michelangelo
is scheduled for release on august 11
2023
as announced by rogan recently the new
youtube feature
share clips has become available on our
channel specifically this means that you
can share 5 to 60 second clips from our
videos with your friends
they can then watch the clip in a loop
directly on the page of the original
video and share the clip via direct
messages like whatsapp and the like
there's also the option to embed the
clip on social networks or
on a website since the project is still
an alpha phase not many channels have
the possibility to use the new feature
at all which is why we are pleased to be
one of the first to present it to you
why don't you give it a try with our
latest news episode let us know what you
think of the new feature in the comments
last year there were already a few
rumors about the upcoming moon night
from marvel
the company is now generating buzz on
twitter because at least one of the
rumors turned out to be completely true
the signing of oscar isaac the disney
plus series which is based on egyptian
icons revolves around the mercenary mark
spectre aka moon knight who suffers from
an identity disorder during a mission in
egypt he just barely escapes death
although in return
he accepts a fateful offer from the god
konshu and becomes his avatar on earth
responsible behind the scenes for
directing is most likely moment diff
while jeremy slater
and bia demaio are primarily responsible
for the script
unfortunately it is still unclear when
exactly moon knight will celebrate its
release
[Applause]
why is it so dark probably would have
been a good idea to have like one light
on
[Music]